[Music]
growing up in India the sheer poverty
and inequality that I had seen made me
very interested in trying to understand
what economics could do and I think what
I discovered during my PhD was that you
could use the tools of Economics to
actually ask much more nuanced questions
about power and politics
why was it that some institutions would
systematically exclude certain groups
and what it would take to give
historically disadvantaged groups
political and economic power
I'm rohini Pandey professor of Economics
at Yale University and director of the
economic growth Center
Central to economics is decided that
there are trade-offs because we have a
finite set of resources and we have to
decide how to allocate them do we do it
through markets and price mechanisms do
we do it through redistribution through
the government
in my own work I'm very interested in
thinking about policy as a tool of
change
[Music]
how can we look at patterns in the world
to try to understand what policies will
increase equality What policies will
lead to trade-offs between economic
well-being and social justice and I
think that's the power of Economics when
it's well done is actually being able to
quantify those trade-offs foreign
[Music]
and repeatedly what we heard was this
concern that if a woman or young girl
had a phone she would get a boyfriend
and it seemed that there was something
linked between very much based on the
caste system these Notions of Purity and
controlling forenews of women
oh
[Music]
we go to the field and then really talk
to them through a set of questions to
understand their economic lives their
social lives their preferences their
behavior
[Music]
we typically end up serving both a woman
and her husband because one of the
things that we're interested in is also
looking at whether on the similar
questions they may have very different
responses a woman might think that a
mobile phone is appropriate for a woman
to use but her husband may not think it
is and that Discord may be very
informative of what actually happens
[Music]
certainly I think a central part of
Economics is the toolkit it's the way of
thinking about abstraction of how do you
go from just seeing everything that's
happening in the world to distill it
down to one force that you can focus on
and say that was something that affected
behavior and I think that's something
economics is very good at
but I think it's dangerous to take it to
the next step of saying that as a result
we know something about what's going to
make people wealthier or happier
I think to understand that you have to
have a much more nuanced view of
politics or power economics can get to
that but I think that's where a little
bit more humility and learning from
other disciplines is valuable
economics is also I think being pushed
in the right direction by a lot of the
social movements that we are seeing
around issues of inclusion of Justice
economists have to think hard about how
do we actually think of Notions of
Justice not just efficiency
[Music]
foreign